ce sont les chercheurs chinois qui ont
les premiers découvert l'efficacité de
ce traitement pour le coc vite 19 la
chloroquine une molécule utilisée selon
sa forme soit pour le traitement du
paludisme soit contre la polyarthrite
on parle alors diderot xi chloroquine en
france c'est le professeur didier raoult
la marseille qui a annoncé des résultats
très encourageants d'un premier test sur
24 personnes associées à un antibiotique
des gens qui avaient pris de l'hydroxyde
rock il plus de l'asie trop micinn avait
une réaction qui était encore plus
spectaculaire puisque ils étaient
pratiquement tous curé de la présence de
virus
au bout de six jours et par ailleurs
alors c'est plus difficile à quantifier
mais il y avait une amélioration
subjectif des patients extrêmement
rapidement à 24 ou 48 heures 24 patients
testés ce n'est pas beaucoup
seulement une dizaine d'études ont été
lancés en même temps deux par le monde
et les premiers résultats rapportés vont
dans le même sens alors tant le
président américain que le gouvernement
français ont annoncé prendre la piste au
sérieux le chu fera partie des prochains
essais cliniques en essai clinique
nationale qui va qui va avec est en
train de commencer auxquels nous allons
participer ou on va pouvoir tester
comparer scientifiquement plusieurs
médicaments potentiellement actif ce
médicament est un médicament qui
existent déjà qui est utilisé dans
d'autres pathologies donc c'est pas une
question de dispositions c'est une
question aujourd'hui qu' on n'est pas
certain qu'il est efficace par contre on
est certain qu'il entraîne un certain
nombre d'effets indésirables
le maire de nice christian estrosi est
cependant soigné avec ces médicaments
alors sont ils disponibles en martinique
le président de l'ordre des pharmaciens
à quatre boîtes dans son officine et une
seule de l'antibiotique il faut dire que
dès février les premières informations
avaient provoqué une commande massive
chez les grossistes les stocks ont été
vidés pour les concernant le site romain
de ses génériques
dès que des
il ya les informations à circuler il
faut savoir que ces médicaments ne sont
valides et en traitement curatif pas du
tout entendement préventif donc ça ne
sert à rien d'aller chercher ses
médicaments par an ainsi d'autant plus
qu'on est en rupture
les laboratoires novartis en suisse et
sanofi en france ont annoncé la mise à
disposition de la chloroquine ou de son
cousin 300000 plaquettes pour sanofi
combien sont disponibles en martinique
pas de réponse chiffrée du côté de
sanofi les boîtes disponibles aurait été
gelés par l' agence régionale de santé
pour éviter une vente abusive conduisant
à la rupture de stock